one piece Finally Revealed imusama's
devil fruit and this devil fruit could
be the dark counterpart of Luffy's Nika
fruit Luffy's gear fifth turns his hair
in much of his clothing white he becomes
a creature known as the Sun God and he
is said to bring freedom and joy to
everyone around him emu is dressed in
all black and his devil fruit Powers
turn him into a dark monster while
droyboi is a warrior of Liberation who
brings laughter and joy and who promises
to reveal the truth and liberate
everyone emu oppresses the world from
the Shadows hides the truth in darkness
and erases history emu is as close as it
gets to the exact opposite of a warrior
of Liberation since Nika has the power
to turn imagination into reality and
make dreams come true maybe emu's
anti-nika power is to turn fears and
Nightmares into reality subscribe to
anime uproar right now for more one
piece